اهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده من برنامجكم
بعد الصافره معي انا عبيد نفع
[موسيقى]
ريال مدريد امبارح كان عنده مباراه مع
الاهلي المصري في نصف نهائي كاس العالم
للانديه معظم الناس طبعا تابعتها وشافت
اللي صار فيها نتيجه المباراه كانت اربع
واحد لريال مدريد ولكن على ارض الواقع هل
النتيجه فعلا كانت تعبر عن مجرى المباراه
لا اعتقد ذلك لانه بكل بساطه الاهلي
المصري قدم مباراه كبيره بشوط المباراه
الاول
ولولا خطا بارجاع الكره لانتهي الشوط
الاول بالتعادل السلبي بين الفريقين وكان
ممكن مجرى المباراه كله يتغير بشوط
المباراه الثانيه ريال مدريد دخل بقوه
اكثر ونجح بتسجيل هدف الثاني ولكن بعد ذلك
الاهلي كان قادر انه يتحصل على ركله جزاء
سجلها علي معلول وحاول اكثر من مره على
مرمى ريال مدريد وكاد ان يسجل الهدف
الثاني عن طريق مجدي قفشه هذا بيدل على
انه دفاع ريال مدريد ما كان ذلك الدفاع
القوي لانه كان مخترق من جانب دفاع الاهلي
المصري اللي كان قادر يشكل عليه ثلاث او
الافرس خطيره جدا ومحققه للتسجيل الامر
المقلق هذا يعني يثير حفيظه اكيد ويثير
قلق جمهور ريال مدريد لانه الاهلي متل ما
حكينا كان مسيطر ببعض دقائق المباراه وكان
قريب من التسجيل لذلك رغم اوكي بتفهم انه
في غيابات بتفهم انه في ناس مش موجوده وهي
قوام الفريق الاساسيه مثل كورتوا وبنزيما
وغيرهم من اللاعبين ولكن رغم ذلك
بدلاء ريال مدريد الموجودين على دكه بدلاء
لازم يكونوا او بمستوى انك تلعب مع ريال
مدريد ريال عنده مباراه قويه جدا امام
الهلال في نهائي كاس العالم للانديه هاي
المباراه راح تحط ريال مدريد امام ضغط
كبير برايي الشخصي وراح يكون الضغط عليه
اكبر بمراحل من الضغط على الهلال ريال
مدريد مطالب بتحقيق نتيجه ايجابيه وتحقيق
اللقب امام الهلال والا راح تكون كارثه
فعلا قد تؤدي لاقاله انشيلوتي لذلك الحديث
عن انه هل يستطيع الهلال هزيمه ريال مدريد
اذا كسر العامل النفسي نعم يستطيع الهلال
قادر على تحقيق اللقب الفرق بين الهلال
والاهلي المصري يكمن بجوده المحترفين جوده
محترفين الهلال على بشوي او بكثير ما بعرف
من جوده لاعبيه او جوده محترفين اهل
المصري لذلك اعتقد اذا الهلال نجح انه
يركز يقدم المباراه والاداء اللي بيقدمها
بالحاله الطبيعيه رح ينجح بانه يتغلب على
ريال مدريد بالنهائي ويحقق اللقب بالمقابل
ريال مدريد لازم يدخل بقوه وما يراهن او
يغامر على الدقائق الاخيره من عمر
المباراه ولازم يحاول يسجل اكبر عدد من
الاهداف بالمرحله او الشوط الاول من
المباراه لحتى يريح نفسه بشوط المباريات
الثاني وما يدخل بحسابات معقده مشكله ريال
مدريد الرئيسيه انه بكل صراحه ما عنده عمق
تشكيل مثل ما حكينا نص الملعب
مش بنفس المستوى لذلك احيانا سيبايوس ممكن
ينزل ويعوض شوي هذا النزول بالرتم او
النزول بالعطاء البدني هذين اللاعبين
بالاضافه لذلك طبعا كلنا بنعرف معضله
الجهه اليسرى والظهير الايسر لريال مدريد
اللي حاليا عم بيلعب فيه كمافينجا ترقيع
بكل امانه حتى على الجهه اليمين وجود
فالفيردي ايضا ترقيع يعني مش اللاعب
الرئيسي اللي لازم او الاساسي او اللي
قادر يقدم لك اضافه اللي بيلعب على هاي
الجهه لانه فالفيردي هذا مش مركزه الاساسي
وكمافينجا هذا مش مركز الاساسي هن بس عم
يغطوا ثغرات موجوده بخطه او بتشكيله ريال
مدريد فينيسيوس جونيور والعامل الفردي
المشكله الكبيره اللي عم يعاني منها
فينيسيوس ايضا هذا الموسم خلته يعني مش
فعال بالنسبه او بالشكل اللي كان عليه
الموسم الماضي اضف الى ذلك انه فينيسيوس
نفسيا غير مستقر لما بيتعرض للاستفزاز من
لاعبي الخصم يعني مبارح كان في رهانات
كثيره على انه محمد هاني عمرو السوليه بعض
اللاعبين ممكن يطلعوا فينيسيوس عن تركيزه
ويخلوه مش مركز شوي ولكن هذا الامر ما حصل
ورغم ذلك فينيسيوس نعم سجل هدف ولكن ما
كان ذلك اللاعب الخطير فنز فينيسيوس ايضا
اثر كثير على القوه الهجوميه تبع ريال
مدريد غياب بديل بنزيما ايضا مشكله اخرى
غياب بديل كورتوا مشكله اخرى غياب ميريتاو
الان ايضا مشكله فريق ريال مدريد يعاني من
عده مشاكل وريال مدريد ليس ريال مدريد
الذين اعرفه والذي عرفناه الموسم الماضي
فرس الهلال مثل ما حكينا اراها قائمه بقوه
اذا راهن على اسلوبه وعلى طريقته وثق
بنفسه وقدم المستويات اللي قدمها بمباراه
فلامنجو لانه برايي الشخصي دفاع ريال
مدريد قابل للاختراق وسط ريال مدريد قابل
للاختراق هجوم ريال مدريد مش ذلك الهجوم
القوي المرعب اللي تعودنا عليه بالحاله
الطبيعيه بوجود كريم بنزيما بالنهايه هاي
بتبقى توقعات ونتيجه المباراه بتظلها ليوم
المباراه ولكن هل سيتفوق ريال مدريد على
الهلال ولا سيصنع الفريق السعودي معجزه
ويحقق اللقب الاول في مونديال الانديه
لقاره اسيا هذا امر متروك للايام هذا كان
كل شيء بحلقه لون بعض الصافره حتى نلتقي
الاسبوع المقبل تكونوا بالف خير
[تصفيق]